la guerra nucrania es un auténtico drama
ojo no solo para los ucranianos que son
por supuesto las víctimas de una
invasión criminal sino también para la
propia Rusia por mucho que el régimen de
Putin se esfuerce en hacer creer lo
contrario a las pérdidas económicas de
las cuales ya os hemos hablado haciendo
mucho tiempo aquí en visualpolitik y
también en nuestro boletín exclusivo
para patrón hay que sumarle las pérdidas
militares que son todavía mucho
muchísimo más importantes por ejemplo en
el momento en el que preparamos Este
vídeo desde que viera comienza la guerra
Rusia ha tenido según los cálculos
occidentales que ha sido 200.000 bajas
entre soldados muertos o incapaces de
combatir por haber sido heridos 200.000
Bajas para que os hagáis una idea esto
serían ocho veces más bajas en un solo
año de guerra que todas las que tuvo
Estados Unidos en sus dos décadas en
Afganistán ocho veces más casi nada por
supuesto además muchos de estos soldados
tendrán secuelas físicas y psicológicas
de por vida sin embargo no esto no
parece que esté siendo un motivo que
haga que el kremlin se replantee la
guerra sabéis que la verdad es que no
debería sorprendernos demasiado
[Música]
históricamente la tradición militar rusa
no ha sido precisamente conocida por
valorar y proteger la vida de sus
soldados bien por carecer de esa
sensibilidad o por falta de medios Las
Guerras han salido ser un picadero de
carne para Moscú un ejemplo lo tenemos
en la Segunda Guerra Mundial en la que
murieron más de 8 millones de soldados
soviéticos de los cuales de todos ellos
más de 6 millones y medio fueron rusos Y
sí es cierto la rusa de Putin no es la
unión soviética pero la Guerra de
Ucrania nos ha demostrado que en la
práctica esa mentalidad no ha cambiado
demasiado Rusia sigue dispuesta a pagar
elevadísimos costes humanos con tal de
perseguir sus objetivos militares
todo esto además viene favorecido por la
falta de oposición política y una
ciudadanía terriblemente apática
sometida durante años a las intensas
campañas de propaganda del régimen con
lo que es poco probable que la pérdida
de Vidas pues sea un gran impedimento
para Putin al menos por ahora
de hecho muchos analistas creen que el
gobierno ruso podría soportar todavía
varios cientos de miles de bajas más en
Ucrania sin que el régimen se viera
realmente comprometido y claro esto nos
lleva directamente a otra pregunta si
esto es así de qué forma se puede
detener a Rusia en el campo de batalla
político y militar cuál y su punto débil
si Las bajas no parecen pasarle
demasiada factura a Vladimir Putin Pues
bien la clave queridos amigos está
Precisamente en su armamento en cosas
como los tanques la artillería o la
Aviación ya puedes tener muchos hombres
listos para mandarlos al frente que si
no están bien equipados el resultado
puede ser desastroso especialmente si
enfrente tienen armas relativamente
modernas y no no estamos hablando de
[__] y empezar a bombardear O mejor
dicho hacer explotar a destruir
siniestro fábricas de armamento rusas
para nada en este vídeo os vamos a
contar cómo se está reduciendo
exactamente la capacidad militar de
Rusia y os contaremos como las sanciones
están afectando a la industria militar
Así que queridos amigos amigas sin más
preámbulo arranquemos
[Música]
desarmando al gigante
no es ningún secreto las pérdidas de
Harvard militar ruso en Ucrania están
siendo devastadoras para el que se creía
que era el segundo ejército más poderoso
del planeta mientras que a Ucrania le
suplen un montón de países tanto armas
como municiones Rusia al menos hasta
ahora está prácticamente sola en esta
guerra y os voy a dar unos datos para
que os hagáis a la idea de lo que
estamos hablando Exactamente para
mediados de diciembre según el
secretario de defensa del Reino Unido
Rusia había perdido 4.500 blindados de
ellos unos 1800 serían tanques luego
además 63 aviones 70 helicópteros 150
drones 12 buques de guerra y más de 600
sistemas de artillería Así mismo ha
llegado a disparar hasta 20.000
proyectiles por día y el lanzamiento de
misiles de precisión ha estado muy pero
que muy por encima de su capacidad de
producción algo que por cierto de algún
modo también ha sucedido en ocasiones
con los propios aliados de Ucrania
Ucrania está quemando munición más
rápido de lo que Estados Unidos y la
otan pueden producirla la diferencia es
que no solo las fábricas de Estados
Unidos y del resto de países pueden
proporcionar armas o municiones a
Ucrania también se están comprando
suministros en otros países para luego
enviárselos al ejército ucraniano Es
evidente que la chequera occidental es
muy grande como también lo puede ser su
capacidad Industrial en relativamente
poco tiempo sin embargo los rusos no
tienen hoy por hoy esa capacidad y desde
luego nadie O al menos nadie serio
Espera que la vayan a tener en un futuro
de hecho su capacidad de fabricar
equipamiento militar se ha degradado
mucho en los últimos meses en parte
Gracias a las sanciones internacionales
y este queridos amigos amigas es un
elemento que puede llegar a resultar
clave
muchos cargos militares y analistas
occidentales creen que si Rusia no
consigue mantener su industria militar
en funcionamiento la guerra podría
llegar a terminar por falta de armas con
el consiguiente bochorno para Vladimir
Putin una situación que podría marcar su
propio final ahora bien esta estrategia
Es realmente realista tiene Rusia las de
ganar o las de perder ante una guerra de
desgaste en el criminal parecen pensar
que lo primero que estarían de
Enhorabuena pero realmente esto así pues
veréis hay al menos dos grandes motivos
para pensar que Rusia lo va a tener
extremadamente difícil en los próximos
meses para suplir de armas su campaña
militar mucho más incluso de lo que lo
ha tenido hasta ahora el primero las
restricciones a las exportaciones a
Rusia y es que veréis como ya os hemos
contado en vídeos pasados aquí en
visualpolitik tanto la industria civil
como la industria militar de Rusia son
terriblemente ineficientes y en general
están tecnológicamente desfasadas y son
dependientes de otros países por este
motivo la prohibición de vender
elementos clave para la industria rusa
ha sido una de las principales puntas de
lanza de la estrategia occidental
hablamos no solo de tecnologías
puramente militares sino sobre todo de
los llamados equipos de doble uso
hablamos de tecnología de vanguardia que
no son puramente militares pero podría
usarse con ese fin Como por ejemplo
semiconductores avanzados ópticas y
sensores o incluso software
este tipo de sanciones están provocando
pérdidas en la producción por falta de
insumos lo cual no solo redunda en una
menor capacidad de producción de equipos
de combate también hace que las unidades
que salen de fábrica bien sean nuevas o
reacondicionadas lo hagan con tecnología
mucho más básica queréis ejemplo pues
fijaos plan de tanques de Rusia coges un
t-62 de 60 años de antigüedad le
instalas nuevas ópticas y le mandas a
Ucrania para que lo exploten mientras
sacan hasta 800 t62 del almacenamiento
de largo plazo El fabricante de tanques
rusosura Alba Gonzalo y está equipando
algunos de ellos con la mira térmica
analógica que es una generación más
nueva que la mira anterior del t-62 ojo
tanques de principios de los 60 les
ponen una nueva mira y un par de
cosillas más y ya resta el incompletado
para Ucrania este es supuestamente es un
plan de 3 años de duración pero tenerlo
claro los cacharros que estén listos
irán a parar automáticamente y a la
desesperada a Ucrania Pero eso eso no es
todo a los tanques más modernos como los
t80 o los t 14 armata que supuestamente
son la Joya la corona del ejército ruso
también les están poniendo esas mismas
ópticas que son mucho menos avanzadas
que las que tenían originalmente Y es
que os hago una pregunta sabéis de dónde
procedían por ejemplo la mayoría de
todas esas miras térmicas y ópticas
avanzadas que se equipaban con orgullo
en los tanques rusos Pues sí exacto no
eran originarias de Rusia ni mucho menos
sino que procedían de países
occidentales o de su órbita como es por
ejemplo el caso de Japón o de Francia
entre muchos otros
[Música]
según documentos clasificados obtenidos
por la organización francesa de
periodismo de investigación disclos las
empresas talesis habrían suministrado el
ejército ruso tecnologías militares
occidentales muy avanzadas hablamos por
ejemplo de ópticas modernas para más de
mil tanques así como sistemas de
navegación tacan para 60 sujo y 30 y
detectores infrarrojos para aviones de
combate también habrían suministrado
sistemas de Mira para helicópteros como
52 algunas de estas tecnologías habrían
sido entregadas por empresas francesas a
Rusia hasta el año 2020 es decir hasta
mucho Después de la invasión de crimea y
el donbas de 2014
[Música]
Estos son solo algunos ejemplos Pero la
realidad es que la industria militar
rusa es muy dependiente de componentes
occidentales de todo tipo en cuanto
quiere fabricar algo con una cierta
complejidad tecnológica
por ejemplo según un importante cinta
británico de seguridad y defensa los
giroscopios de fibra óptica que equipan
los misiles guiados de 300 milímetros
que luego se utilizan en los lanzadores
tornados s eran de fabricación
estadounidense o Tenemos también el caso
de los vehículos militares del
fabricante que ha tenido que detener la
producción de todas sus plataformas
modernas de uso militar porque Los
inyectores de combustible Pues eran de
la marca alemana Bosch Incluso el
sistema de defensa aérea ruso tor m2 uno
de los más potentes de corto alcance
tiene componentes británicos que
controlan el radar de la plataforma es
decir en resumidas cuentas que en cuanto
nos vamos a armas un poquito más
sofisticadas que pueden llegar en cierto
modo a competir con el armamento
occidental Pues resulta que
prácticamente ninguna es 100% rusa
prácticamente todas tienen algún
componente o tecnología de países que
ahora ya no se la proporcionan y como os
podéis imaginar pues esto les obliga o
bien a no poder fabricar estas unidades
o bien a buscar sustitutos para estos
componentes sustitutos mucho más
anticuados lo que evidentemente pues
reduce normalmente sus capacidades de
combate y claro eso en última instancia
Pues digamos que debilita el ejército de
Putin en su conjunto
en general se calcula que las sanciones
internacionales contra Rusia en las que
están directamente implicados más de 30
países han desplomado sus importaciones
en más de un 40% en el año 2022 y eso es
teniendo en cuenta las sanciones
posteriores al 24 de febrero del 2022 es
decir a las sanciones que se impusieron
después de la invasión porque luego
también están las que se impusieron tras
la invasión de crimea y el don Bach
sanciones que se orientaron sobre todo a
la compra de equipos y suministros
militares sanciones que no le han
permitido a Rusia producir tanto
armamento avanzado ni modernizar al
ritmo esperado sus fuerzas armadas
quizás Putin pensaba que ocupar
territorio ucraniano no iba a tener
ninguna consecuencia en esta línea por
ejemplo Rusia tenía un acuerdo de compra
de cuatro buques de asalto anfibio
Mistral con Francia un acuerdo que Fue
cancelado tras estos acontecimientos
pero al margen de los miembros de la
otan otros países que no han aplicado
inicialmente sanciones también han
reducido últimamente su comercio con
Rusia de forma voluntaria digamos que
para no tener Consecuencias negativas en
los mercados occidentales mercados que
evidentemente son mucho más importantes
que el Ruso y esto no acaba aquí para
nada hay al menos otro motivo para
pensar que Rusia lo va a tener muy pero
que muy difícil para producir armas al
ritmo al que las está consumiendo y es
simple y llanamente el factor económico
puro y duro
[Música]
pensadlo bien mantener a flote la
capacidad militar en una guerra que dura
ya más de un año y en la que
prácticamente Estás solo sin apoyo de
nadie más es algo que cuesta mucho
muchísimo dinero y las sanciones
evidentemente no le han venido nada bien
a la economía rusa y además no podemos
olvidar que por muy grande que pueda ser
prusiano deja de tener un pibe per
cápita similar al de países como
Argentina o Rumanía Pues bien El caso es
que aunque los datos oficiales sobre el
coste de la invasión para Rusia están
clasificados se estima que el
presupuesto militar super ampliamente el
5% del pib en 2022 alcanzando así un
récord no visto desde los tiempos de la
unión soviética podemos amigos amigas
estar hablando fácilmente de unos 95.000
millones de dólares lo que supondría una
desviación respecto al presupuesto
proyectado de más del 40 por ciento es
de cajón la guerra no ha sido tan corta
como esperaban y por tanto tampoco tan
barata ahora bien En qué parte entran en
juego las sanciones en toda esta
historia
[Música]
Pues básicamente las sanciones
económicas como el fin de la importación
de gas O el tope al precio al petróleo
ruso entre muchas otras y están
empezando a impactar considerablemente
en las cuentas públicas de Rusia por
ejemplo según los datos ojo del propio
gobierno ruso el déficit Federal en los
dos primeros meses del año ascendió a
2,6 millones de rublos esto es unos 34
mil millones de dólares esta cifra
supone el
88%. el 88% de todo el déficit fiscal
previsto por el gobierno ruso para todo
el 2023 de esta forma según las
estimaciones de la escuela de economía
de gif y de varios analistas el agujero
real en los presupuestos en 2023 puede
llegar a ser tres o cuatro veces mayor
que en 2022 al ritmo actual el gobierno
consumirá por completo el fondo nacional
ruso de inversión antes de finalizar el
año Este es el fondo que supuestamente
tenía que asegurar la capacidad
económica del gobierno ruso ante
situaciones extraordinarias situaciones
como la Guerra de Ucrania hablamos de
unos 150.000 millones de dólares de
ahorros a comienzos del 2023 que podrían
consumirse en apenas unos pocos meses y
sabéis que a partir de ese momento los
problemas para Moscú podrían
multiplicarse porque básicamente sólo
tendría dos opciones para mantener el
esfuerzo de guerra o financiar la
contienda con emisión de deuda pública
en el mercado financiero local lo que
incrementaría los tipos de interés y el
propio definir del gobierno o monetizar
deuda con emisiones del Banco Central lo
que podría disparar la inflación Y es
que queridos amigos amigas los ingresos
del gobierno ruso por las ventas de
petróleo y gas durante el arranque del
2023 se han reducido un 46% respecto al
mismo periodo del año anterior y eso no
es todo el resto de ingresos no ligados
a los hidrocarburos también se están
desplomando digan lo que digan las cosas
no marchan bien
[Música]
esta situación está obligando al kremlin
a incluir dentro de los presupuestos de
las regiones la compra de equipamiento
militar es decir que los gobiernos
locales y regionales han perdido no solo
su poder sino también su recursos ya que
parte de su presupuesto ahora se gastan
defensa para que os hagáis una idea los
gastos del Estado ruso fueron un 58% más
altos en enero de 2023 que en el mismo
mes de 2022 Y eso según datos oficiales
[Música]
evidentemente Cuanto más fuerza
financiero tenga que hacer el estado
ruso para financiar su guerra más
dificultades tendrá para poder hacerlo
por eso las sanciones económicas al
margen de los efectos que puedan tener
sobre otros Campos Como por ejemplo la
opinión pública también tiene un impacto
directo a la capacidad militar ahora
bien no estaríamos contando toda la
historia si pasásemos por alto como la
industria de defensa rusa y el propio
estado se han ido adaptando a todas
estas circunstancias y es que
evidentemente cuando te imponen
sanciones pues te las intentas saltar Y
por supuesto el caso de Rusia no es
diferente Ahora bien Hasta qué punto lo
están logrando Pues bien veámoslo
innovar para matar
no os vamos a engañar los rusos están
demostrando cierta capacidad para
saltarse algunas de las sanciones
internacionales impuestas y así poder
seguir con su campaña criminal en
Ucrania sin embargo ellos adelantó que
esto más que medidas efectivas son sólo
una manera de ganar tiempo y es que
veréis Moscú está adquiriendo
semiconductores y Microchips así como
otros componentes de alta tecnología en
teoría de uso civil a través de países
no adheridos a las sanciones o con
imposición de sanciones menos duras como
China kazajistán o Turquía ya os hemos
hablado de ello también aquí en
visualpolitik eso sí El problema es que
esta vía pues permite comprar muchos
menos productos tecnológicos que antes
por mucho que algunos de ellos tengan
componentes occidentales a los que ahora
no tendrían acceso de forma directa En
todo caso ni siquiera podemos hablar de
que las acciones no estén funcionando
porque Es evidente con todo lo que os
hemos contado que el tejido Industrial
ruso está muy lejos de sus mejores días
producen sí la industria militar rusa
producir produce pero equipos mucho
menos avanzados que antes de la invasión
de hecho algunas de las evidencias que
hacen pensar que Rusia todavía consigue
componentes para fabricar algunas armas
avanzadas se han conseguido en la propia
Ucrania por ejemplo el análisis de los
restos de algunos misiles de precisión
rusos kh 101 lanzados contra gif
recientemente han revelado que fueron
fabricados entre septiembre y octubre de
2022 es decir Rusia puede seguir
fabricando armamento avanzado aunque no
en la cantidad y calidad necesaria para
enfrentarse a todo el armamento
occidental que está llegando a Ucrania
incluidos por primera vez tanques
relativamente modernos como los leopard
para que os hagáis una idea del
decrépito estado de sus almacenes
armamentísticos Rusia ya ha empezado a
disparar misiles fabricados en la época
soviética y esto se sabe porque las
armas rusas en especial los misiles
lanzados contra Ucrania se analizaban en
la medida de lo posible Pues bien Por
ejemplo a comienzos del 2023 se analizó
un misil lanzado contra la ciudad de
deni pro y resultó ser un kh 22 un tipo
de misil cuya producción empezó Ni más
ni menos que en el año 1962 y que son
terriblemente imprecisos de hecho
terminó impactando contra un edificio de
viviendas matando a decenas de personas
el edificio Residencial ending Pro fue
alcanzado por un misil kh 22 que no
puede ser derribado por la defensa aérea
ucraniana en fin de locos pero todavía
hay algo más
[Música]
otro de los ejemplos sobre cómo Rusia
trata de evadir las sanciones que
afectan a su capacidad militar lo
tenemos en la importación de los famosos
drones iraníes de los que tanto se ha
hablado aunque no ha sido el único caso
también han importado tanques y
blindados de Bielorrusia Y se cree que
municiones de artillería de Corea del
Norte en fin ya lo veis buscando ayuda
en lo mejor de cada casa pero ahora bien
llegados hasta aquí qué podemos aprender
de la experiencia de más de un año ya de
guerra y de todas las sanciones
aplicadas contra Rusia pues
principalmente la elección es una las
sanciones no pueden ser la única vía
para desgastar a Moscú porque su efecto
llegará sobre todo en el medio y largo
plazo Así que nos servirían de nada sin
el constante apoyo militar Ucrania en
forma de entrega de armas si los
ucranianos no tienen la fuerza necesaria
para multiplicar el coste para Rusia en
el frente y no solo en vida sino también
en armas Entonces es probable que Moscú
no tenga tantos problemas para alargar
su campaña militar es algo de lo que ya
os hemos hablado con todo lujo de
detalles en un vídeo que os dejo por
aquí abajo en la descripción sea como
sea la pregunta ahora es para ti después
de todo lo que hemos visto crees que las
sanciones a Rusia están surtiendo efecto
en el campo militar deberíamos
incrementar la entrega de armas Ucrania
todavía más como siempre déjanos tu
opinión aquí abajo en los comentarios y
ahora si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros al politic si es que aún no
lo habéis hecho una vez más Muchísimas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]